[Musique]
pendant des années, notre monde a été en paix,
mais quelque chose arrive, je peux sentir que
des forces obscures sont sur nous trouver ces
bêtes ou quoi qu'elles soient notre monde est en
train de mourir il n'y a rien à retourner si
notre peuple veut survivre nous devons  faire
tout un média quoi qu'il arrive ce qui
se passe si nous ne nous unissons pas notre monde
périra cela n'a pas besoin d'arriver
il y en a un qui peut nous aider il n'y a pas d'
autre vie
non mais avec la cellule humaine
il pourrait y avoir pourquoi es-tu ici pour  sauver
tout le monde pouvons-nous lui faire confiance
les bêtes qu'ils devraient tous être détruits
êtes-vous sûr de cela
nous protégerons pour vous garder et moi à l'intérieur
avec un humour contre votre propre
espèce c'est du suicide nous n'avons pas le choix nous
devrions attaquer de toute force quoi que ce soit
vous envisagez de faire